[Musik]
das akw lakata lebte wo die täter haben
meistens wenig zu befürchten und die
stimmung in dem land kocht über
[Musik]
gerade jetzt in zeiten der pandemie
häufen sich die fälle häuslicher gewalt
was zur hölle ist da nur los in mexiko
ich bin in mexiko city und ich möchte
herausfinden warum gewalt gegen frauen
in mexiko so ein riesenproblem ist ich
habe auf instagram von der demo mit
bekommen die ihr gleich stattfinden soll
und ich bin gespannt was da so geht
[Musik]
mit den hersteller - nicht einem er
nicht ein weniger wachen aktivistinnen
im netz auf die dramatische situation
der frauen aufmerksam sie organisieren
sich und sie tragen ihre stimme raus auf
die straße
so wie heute der protest ist zu einer
riesen bewegung geworden viele der
demonstrantinnen sind vermummt warum
werde ich gleich erleben
der anlass der demo sind zwei morde die
es kürzlich passierte
victorias tod löste besonders viel
empörung aus sie wurde bei einer
polizeikontrolle am boden fixiert und
erlitt einen genickbruch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
meine freundin helfen mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sagen on the snow also männer so
locker und keine männer hier
am ende der demo finde ich doch doch
eine aktivistin mit der sprechen kann
sie nimmt das mit dem männer verbot
nicht ganz so ernst
[Musik]
die frauen fühlen sich nicht gehört denn
das thema gewalt gegen frauen kommt in
der politik einfach nicht zur sprache
die mexikanische regierung verurteilt
die bewegung niemand ist bereit mit den
radikalen feministinnen in den dialog zu
treten
[Musik]
jetzt würde ich gerne hören was hier zu
den gewalttätigen methoden der
demonstranten denn sagt findet ihr es
gut so aufmerksamkeit auf das thema zu
lenken oder lehnt ihr die gewalttätigen
methoden der dem kanton bern ab schreibt
mir in die kommentare
es sind vor allem die mütter der opfert
ihren protest nun immer lauter an die
öffentlichkeit tragen
ich möchte eine von ihnen kennen lernen
meine recherche reise beginnt in dem
bundesstaat hidalgo
das ist ungefähr zwei stunden nördlich
von mexiko city und in einem dieser
häuser wohnt eva die ich jetzt treffen
werde
[Musik]
vor einem jahr verlor er war ihre
tochter gina heute ist sie breitbild mir
darüber zu sprechen ist dass fotos die
nacktfotos minister denn er ist da china
lernte enrique auf facebook kennen
schnell wurde es zu einer toxischen
beziehung die china nicht mehr verlassen
konnte
ihr freund war eifersüchtig kontroll
süchtig brutal
als sie ihn verlassen wollte brachte er
gina um das was in den medien oft als
beziehungsdrama verharmlost wird ist
strukturell und hat einen namen film
easy die chemie zieht also die tötung
von frauen aus purem hass auf sie der
begriff wurde in den neunzigern geprägt
als eine frauenmord serie die
nordmexikanischen grenzstadt hoher rees
erschütterte
seitdem hat sich wenig an der situation
in mexiko verbessert das vergangene jahr
war laut statistiken dass mit den
meisten filmen seit 30 jahren alleine in
den vergangenen fünf jahren stieg die
für mit zitaten mexiko um ganze 60
prozent auf chemie zieht stehen in
mexiko 40 bis 60 jahre haft
theoretisch denn tatsächlich bleiben
hier unglaubliche 93 prozent aller
verbrechen gegen frauen unbestraft so
auf chinas fall
also gehört nur 900 euro soll
mannschaftskasse martin noch live band
aus kassel sind manche noch genannten
kann pedro kasse machen will sollte in
ganz mexiko gelten laut der nationalen
subkommission der regierung aktuell
21.000 frauen als vermisst
vermisstenfälle und fehmi ziele gehen
auf hand in hand und das justizsystem
ist überfordert
es ist für mich unvorstellbar die
definitionen wie bei dem von china zum
beispiel überhaupt nicht ermittelt wird
ich bin deswegen heute nacht mit der
polizei unterwegs reicht wissen möchte
hier gearbeitet wird
[Musik]
dafür treffe ich mich mit juli zeh
hernandez im osten mexiko citys leitet
sie eine polizeieinheit
bei ihr geht vor allem vermisstenfälle
und fälle von häuslicher gewalt ein
heute nacht darf ich juni zu begleiten
selbst
es dann aus der musiker bela klentze
soleimani priorität zeigt mir das ausmaß
der gewalt und dann hat juritischen alle
hände voll zu tun
diese frau vermisst ihre 16 jahre alte
tochter und das in einer metropole mit
21 millionen einwohnerinnen und
einwohnern
die mutter wird in eine
überwachungszentrale begleitet hier hat
die polizei zugriff auf sämtliche
überwachungskameras mexiko citys der
letzte anhaltspunkt ihrer vermissten
tochter ist ein taxi mit denen das
mädchen nach hause kommen sollte bevor
mit personal am boden gesucht wird
leidet der ermittler eine sogenannte
digitale suche ein und wird tatsächlich
fündig ich habe mir von einer
journalistin sagen lassen dass diese
wache vorbildlich arbeitet vielleicht
war es deswegen auch einfach eine
drehgenehmigung zu bekommen ob frauen in
anderen polizeistationen genauso ernst
genommen werden wir hier ist unklar
und dann geht es für ried sie erst mal
auf streife ich möchte von ihr wissen
was sie zu dem aufschrei im land sorgt
dazu dass hier kaum jemand an eine faire
rechtsprechung glaubt
so jung hat vermietern
doch wie geht sie damit um dass das
system von einer vorwiegend gruppen
männerwelt bestimmt wird
[Musik]
die nacht verläuft ruhig zurück auf dem
revier möchte ich von juri zu wissen was
sie zu dem film zieht an china sagt ich
zeige dir mein interview mit eva
während alle polizistinnen sowie judith
sie könnte das patriarchat einpacken
es braucht zumindest innen wie sie um
das system von innen heraus verändern zu
können
ich treffe mich mit gonzalo der
eigentlich anders heißt aber die scham
vor dem was er getan hat sei einfach zu
groß sein gesicht dürfen wir zeigen hier
lebt er zusammen mit seiner neuen
partnerin
klar scheint zu sein die wurzel des
problems liegt in der mexikanischen
gesellschaft immer wieder begegne ich
bei meinen recherchen dem wort machismo
ein mann bestimmt über die frau sie gilt
als seinem besitz
conzzeta lokale medien
in den doppeln familienprobleme familie
mathys interesses abhängig und somit die
sinfonia zu
und dann erzählt ganz zahlung mir von
seiner ersten ehe seine frau brachte
damals eine tochter mit in die beziehung
konkreter della casa yo gabba
austria.com maria mena
[Musik]
für sozial wissenschaftlerinnen und
sozialwissenschaftler sind das typische
muster für den zunehmenden wunsch der
kontrolle und machtausübung auf seine
partnerin und gonzalo gehen noch viel
weiter
nach dem sexuellen missbrauch seiner
eigenen stieftochter verließ gonzalo
seine frau auf eigenen wunsch wie er
sagt ich muss das alles erst mal
verarbeiten die tatsache dass gonzalo
beruflich als clown arbeitet und sich
kurz nach unserem interviewen solch
einen verwandelt macht es keineswegs
besser
[Musik]
als clown könne er vergessen was er
schreckliches getan hat weil er andere
menschen kein leid sondern freude bringe
ich packe jetzt meine sachen und dann
fahre ich nach tipico
das ist jetzt ziemlich über gegend hier
in mexiko city und da bin ich mit den
typen verabredet der von sich behauptet
auftragskiller zu sein
es heißt über sieben ecken kennt man
jeden menschen auf der welt und über
drei journalist ische verbindungen trete
ich mit einem mutmaßlichen
auftragsmörder in kontakt mein kontakt
mann der mich begleitet möchte nicht
erkannt werden wir unterhalten uns
während der fahrt
mortara kontext zu helfen er ist das
vielleicht gewohnt ich aber nicht
deshalb gehe ich lieber auf nummer
sicher
ja
wir treffen uns an einem neutralen ort
auftragsmord als dienstleistung das geht
in mexiko ich will wissen wie das läuft
[Musik]
was
was hat bei kabi ag
wenn man die produktion in europa was
carlo masala sondern ich glaube dass
diese heilige progression ist populär
von das papier sondern fragen was sie
gemacht sagt jessica sie als person as
maturierte sehen konnten was die
kontraste sieht aus wie demokratie und
respekt es ist thema der jurist ist ja
situation ist sie in apulien nachholen
am schluss kann ich natürlich nicht
überprüfen ob es stimmt wasser sagt fakt
ist in mexiko passieren diese dinge
tatsächlich allein dass er wenn auch
anonym verlaufender kamera von seinen
frauen worden spricht zeigt doch dass er
wohl wenig zu befürchten hat das gesetz
zielt in mexiko offenbar nicht viel und
ein menschenleben auf nicht 2000 euro um
genau zu sein für so wenig geld habe er
schon eine frau getötet
den aufschrei nach gerechtigkeit findet
man in mexiko buchstäblich an jeder
straßenecke
es wirkt auf mich wie ein teufelskreis
die ohnehin schon hohe kriminalität
überfordert die justiz das system wird
zunehmend korrupter als einfachen
bürgerinnen und bürgern den zugang zu
einer fairen rechtsprechung nahezu
unmöglich macht dadurch verläuft der
großteil der aufklärungsarbeit bei
vielen im sande
oft zeigen von gewalt betroffene frauen
ihr aggressoren gar nicht erst an
ob aus mangelndem vertrauen in die
behörden oder angst vor den tätern die
konsequenz losigkeit gibt aggressoren
einen freifahrtsschein und das wiederum
führt zu noch mehr morden tat man das
ganze dann noch mit einem tief
verankerten machismus erzeugt man eine
gewaltspirale die sich nur sehr schwer
aufhalten lässt
[Musik]
ich treffe mich noch einmal mit gonzalo
und er mir von seinen gewalttaten
erzählt hat seit einigen wochen nimmt er
deshalb an einem anti gewalt training
teil
freiwillig
[Musik]
wenn sie also wirklich das anvisieren
hollywood an
[Musik]
die erfolgschancen der therapie sein
guter klappt mit der gruppenleiter wenn
sich männer wie gonzalo ihren dämonen
freiwillig stellten allerdings gebe es
nicht genügend angebote in mexiko und
die meisten gewalttätige männer sehen
erst gar nicht ein dass sie ein problem
haben
zu was toxische männlichkeit führen kann
hat mir der film zieht am china gezeigt
ich begleite ihre mutter eva zu ihrem
grab zusammen mit chinas hinterbliebene
tochter pancetta
[Musik]
inklusion
bonn - pro jahr soll es noch mit zu
chinas graf zu begleiten ist ein echter
ans herz gegangen
wie geht es euch nach dem film ein tier
das kann gelingen die gewaltspirale
defizit in mexiko zu durchbrechen
schafft es mir bitte in die kommentare
und lass uns da gerne in den gemeinsamen
ausbau stünden